le risque apparaît pour le moment
éloignés mais l'europe s'y prépare
réunion à londres sur la grippe aviaire
les ministres de la santé des 25 n'ont
pas pris de décision mais on fait le
point sur l'état de préparation des
différents pays avec une volonté
affichée rassurer leurs opinions
publiques
pascal verre d'eau tard nasri comment
coordonner au niveau européen les
mesures destinées à éviter la
propagation du virus de la grippe
aviaire pour les ministres de la santé
réunis à londres
le principe de précaution affiché
aujourd'hui prendra corps les 23 et 24
novembre prochains à travers un exercice
d' alerte grandeur nature organisées à
l'échelon européen
en attendant chaque état fourbit ses
armes et complète ses stocks
d'antiviraux la commission européenne
financera des recherches dans le domaine
des vaccins et fera le lien entre les
différents plans nationaux
quant à la communication destinée au
grand public le message des 25 est clair
la grippe aviaire aujourd'hui relève
uniquement de la santé animale ce que
nous constatons aujourd'hui c'est
l'épisode aussi c'est à dire le virus
qui touche les oiseaux comme cela a été
le cas aussi en asie centrale
il y à une autre étape c'est le passage
du virus de l'oiseau à l'homme ceci n'a
été constaté qu en asie du sud-est et
dans quatre pays seulement
est ce que nous redoutons les uns les
autres les scientifiques et se fasse à
quoi nous devons nous préparer c'est le
passage de l'homme à l'homme ceci n'a
été constatée nulle part sur la planète
volonté de rassurer mais dans
l'incertitude agir comme si la pandémie
pouvait se déclarer demain la semaine
prochaine à copenhague les européens
feront le point avec l' oms
l'organisation mondiale de la santé